more no nuance november i guess
this one is simply
if i'm pissing off ben shapiro i must be
doing something right you haven't pissed
me off i don't i don't understand who
you are which which person is this
pronouns em air heirs disease enzosers
or really any nail pronouns that's the
same person well i'm glad this person
grew out their hair
so that's that's good i'm i'm proud of
jesus void mce we've crossed all
barriers now they make tick-tock videos
they respond to the tic-tac videos and
then they completely change into
different characters and respond to my
tic toc videos and then i respond to
their tic tac videos it's an infinite
regress of brain melting stupidity